anyone who gets to play spider-man is
living a dream come true
unfortunately for Andrew Garfield that
dream was brief why was this tenure as
Peter Parker so short the answer as
always is complicated the best
characters often come from actors with a
concrete vision who can turn stories
experiences and research into a coherent
whole
Garfield believed in the power of this
process as fervently as a 25 year old
rookie actor could after the series
cancellation he told the Guardian about
the work he put in behind the scenes to
do right by the character I thought if I
can infuse all this ancient knowledge
and wisdom into spider-man
it could be profoundly affecting for
young people in the audience that was
always my intention and what I tried to
do
unfortunately the studio didn't agree
the cutting of character centric scenes
the promotion of Garfield as a celebrity
and the ultimate reality of the amazing
spider-man as a blockbuster series made
Garfield's highbrow ideas unsustainable
he has at least made peace with this
rift telling The Guardian in the same
interview what I'll proudly say is that
I didn't compromise who I was I was only
ever myself Andrew Garfield is an
actor's actor man that means he was
never going to be satisfied working
entirely in superhero blockbusters ever
since Tom Holland took up the web suit
to flip and quip his way through the MCU
sprawling saga Garfield has devoted
himself almost entirely to cerebral art
house cinema 2016 saw him take part in
Martin Scorsese's silence in which he
played a 17th century Jesuit priest in
2017 he played a polio survivor in the
biopic read most recently he starred in
under the Silverlake a neon noir that
takes his character across Los Angeles
in pursuit of conspiracy at the end of
spider-man pushed Garfield into this
kind of work it's as much a blessing as
it is a curse and perhaps Garfield
himself feels the same way Peter Parker
is a consummate nerd in his debut and
amazing fantasy number 15 he's bitten by
a radioactive spider because he's
visiting a lab after school Peter Parker
just loves science so dearly that he
likes to spend his time discussing the
finer points of atomic energy Cristian
Midtown highs only professional
Wallflower on the very first panel he
ever appeared in he's a geek before he
ever gets the power to climb walls and
swing across New York sure the Amazing
Spider
man movies informants of Peters nerdery
but what we actually see looks very
different of the three actors who make
up Spidey's big screen presence Garfield
is the one who's handsome looks weren't
toned down at all
Garfield's Peter Parker skateboards and
broods with a charisma that's entirely
too cool Maguire Spidey loved to talk
chemistry and hollands gets together
with his best friend Ned to build Lego
models of the Death Star but you can't
really picture Garfield spider-man doing
much in the geek arena beyond maybe
playing the occasional round of Mortal
Kombat he's just too cool and when it
comes to spider-man that's a fatal flaw
the MCU debuted in 2008 with the
explosive arrival of Robert Downey jr.
Tony Stark and Iron Man by 2012 Marvel
Studios had pulled its team together in
the Avengers a blockbuster event that
would usher in what we might just one
day call the Marvel Age of movies and oh
yeah Spiderman was there too of course
with Sony holding the movie rights to
the character he remained trapped in his
own cinematic universe though amazing
spider-man did well at the box office
the fact remained that it was completely
eclipsed by the other Marvel based movie
to come out that year plus the MCU is
demonstrating far more staying power
than Sony Spider flicks in retrospect
the writing was very much on the wall
people were loving Marvel's son equipped
latent vision of their own universe far
more than Sony's slick take on the
iconic webslinger as the years went on
Marvel built up more and more gravity
and spider-man the company's flagship
comic book hero was pulled in and
revamped by Tom Holland there was an
inevitability to this process not even
the best movie could afford it and
unfortunately Garfield's films were far
from the best director Sam Raimi spin on
spider-man feels like ancient history
now but try not to let the memories of
Tobey Maguire dancing in the jazz club
cloud your mind just yet instead
remember alfred molinos trailblazing
performance as a villain at war with
himself
remember Willem Dafoe's lunatic glee at
being able to bombard spider-man with
pumpkin themed bombs
you in or are you out it's you who's out
Gaby out of your mind
remember kirsten dunst is warm-hearted
girl next door remember the upside-down
kiss and perhaps above all remember that
iconic train rescue at the time the
world loved those movies only five years
separate the last of the McGuire trilogy
from the first of the Garfield duo in
some ways that's a long time but it's
not long enough for a generation to turn
over most kids who grew up with McGuire
were barely into adulthood by the time
Garfield rolled around McGuire remained
an a-list star rather than an elder
statesman passing down a beloved role it
was too soon for anyone to erase the
mark left by the first trilogy from
their minds too soon for there to be an
organic desire for a new take on an old
favorite and in the end that's the
desire a superhero flick lives and dies
by check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about spider-man are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]